solar power is suddenly awesome on Fox
news now that these Chinese balloons are
being asserted without evidence to have
extraordinarily Advanced solar power
capabilities this is so fun these Fox
News people are so predictable and and
it's so funny in a way if it weren't so
sad once again Fox News propagandist
Maria Bartiromo is starting to talk
about solar panels and in the context of
the Chinese balloons she again brought
up this is now the second weekend in a
row that Maria brings up they are
getting unlimited power from these solar
panels they have unlimited energy
wow if if now solar panels represent not
some woke distraction from burning
fossil fuels but rather unlimited energy
seems like we should be taking solar
more seriously in the U.S don't you
think here's Maria Bartiromo yesterday
is the CCP option
loons the largest one that you know you
could fit three buses in it that was
shot down over South Carolina last
Saturday that balloon was able to snap
images of our military installations and
send them back to China in live time so
what John Radcliffe told us last week
was spot on they were using solar panels
for unlimited power unlimited energy to
continue the surveillance program damn
those solar panels they're getting the
best of us because they're so awesome
unlimited power it's crazy what about
clouds like Trump said what about night
time like Trump said all of a sudden
solar power the Holy Grail of
surveillance and spying and remember
last weekend she uh proposed something
similar there's China did it drop and
surveillance
yeah without any evidence whatsoever
Maria suggesting you know when they
popped the balloon when Biden popped the
balloon it might have released
micro surveillance elements powered by
the sun which could in perpetuity
surveil the United States wow that it's
amazing such technology even exists with
solar power Maria so solar power sounds
pretty damn awesome now if you watch
Maria bartiromo's program according to
Fox News it sounds like solar energy is
really the way to go so of course we're
sort of being tongue-in-cheek here sort
of being facetious it would be great for
them to just take solar panels and solar
power
10 percent as seriously as they are
taking it now in general rather than
doing their normal stuff it's not sunny
enough in the United States for solar
which will never work oh but what about
when it's cloudy out there we just don't
know just take it 10 as seriously as
you're taking it now and we would all be
way better off